I am speechless that performance tell me
what went into it the amount of
rehearsals and planning and costume
change rehearsal my goodness people
don't have any idea like it's three
minutes I'm up there on stage but they
have no slightest idea all the hard work
blood sweat tears
I literally have bruises on my knees
from however many times I did that split
but it really does take a village you
know my choreographer Sean Bankhead he's
incredible he pushes me to the fullest
of my capacity I swear that man thinks
that I can do any and everything I'm
like you really think that he's like
because you can I did you do like a V
set into a split into a back walkover so
you know there's like oh my goodness
I'm trying thank you I worked really
hard the dancers they kept me energized
on this thing she kept me confident
video it has shook the Internet the
world has blown up what is the reaction
to you have now coined a new whole dance
craze the ball but is there a technical
term for it um you should name it you
should all but the bone your leg gets
the ball and then fun okay the ball but
it's hot it's a whole new genre of dance
yes I mean I think so I think my dance
teacher would agree for sure I'm feeling
right now this is a life-changing moment
for you this is you have worked so long
and put in all the hard work and here
you are stealing the VMAs that's got to
feel like it's honestly a dream come
true like I was just in the restroom I
was taking photos because that's
predictable me but everybody was just
like yo you have a movement like you
have your VMA and I've worked incredibly
hard you know seven eight long years in
preparation of this moment and it's just
really beautiful because it's also the
beginning so I'm just really really
grateful for the opportunity to my fans
that you know voted congratulations to
black this is us this isn't just me you
know
I'm really really blessed and grateful
for him oh my god who's playing that hey
have you seen me oh there she goes she
kills it Hey okay so the front side Mona
and the back side bation I'm sorry this
is my first time I want you right here
Ichi we're gonna watch it together I'm
so excited
and it's custom change time five get off
get off her she's gotta go she's gotta
go and then dance break what's going
through your mind right now right now I
was honestly still freaked out about the
fact that the the situation wasn't
working but I was like you go for it huh
[Music]
okay
I'm so happy you feel so proud right now
probably gonna cry tonight hi this is a
huge moment this is VMAs this is where
pop culture thank you ever played that
this is where pop culture performs us
now you get your page in the VMA history
bus the crazy thing like I study you
know I watched Britney performances with
the snake the most iconic moments and I
feel like the VMAs like any other show
like this is where the biggest moments
in pop culture happen and the fact that
I got to be a part of that tonight is
just really crazy and as myself so god
god is great what did you think of the
other performances Taylor Missy killed I
didn't get to see him no I I haven't
seen anybody else's performance maybe a
glimpse of Missy's and I'm Missy is just
ill she's so deserving listen we're so
proud of you you're so lovely as
beautiful inside as you are outside
thank you everything in the best team in
the world and show us the VMA give us a
little judge and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]